so what i mean to say is
you agree on with uh on the problems
with the the left-wing populists yes the
instagram solutions yes the problem is
these leptin populists won't actually
listen to you because the media tells
them not to
but that's why shows like yours and they
are because i tell you who's listening
people in the rio grande valley the
hispanics the the vanguard of the trump
movement and you're seeing this and
let's talk about the recall of gavin
newsom the golden boy in california 51
of latinos in california when he's
recalled it's because when the core
elements of the traditional democratic
party has said we want this guy out you
know why it's the mass mandates it's the
education we don't want these school
unions they want the teachers we have to
have our kids in school
we have to do it one of the biggest
things we have on the show is woman
lydia friend women of watts and her big
fight is that in a competitive you know
she's a grandmother but she cares for
all these kids and watch she says in a
competitive world economy
kids can't take off a year or two not
have been being schooled at home they
need to be competitive with the kids in
china and the kids in europe
that's why latinos are leading this is
the ironic part of this it's latinos
leading the call of the recall of
gavin newsom in those nine democrats the
nine centuries democrats spread
throughout the country except three of
them are in the rio grande valley in
texas
cuellar vela and uh and uh uh cuellar
vela in gonzales i think it is cory
velas and gonzalez three down there that
are um that are are old school ones
retiring the other two are tough tough
tough democrats but they understand the
rio grande valley is flipping for trump
why border security and illegal aliens
competing for those jobs at the lower
ends of the scale they're driving wages
down
people are rational the reason that
listen this is why the apes are so
important they don't want you to
understand finance they don't want you
to understand economics they don't want
you to understand how the system works i
would tell people hey
you won't have any conspiracy theories
when you start to explain and give
people the information where the system
works
like right now
we've just had bloomberg had this
morning and i think we get to that
bloomberg had this morning that story
since the since the since the uh the ccp
virus four trillion dollars
has been added to to the balance sheet
of the federal reserve to pay for the
drop in agreement all those interim
things four trillion dollars
838 million dollars
an hour wow okay
now we're sitting here in washington dc
they're talking about six trillion
dollars of additional spending do you
understand that this is going to not
your children and your grandchildren you
if you're under 35 years old welcome to
serfdom okay because you're always going
to be just kind of this this uh what
lumping proletariat right you're never
gonna own anything you're not gonna have
any one or two that under that write
some algorithm are the elon musk of the
world yes you'll break out but for the
general population it won't be the days
of america where you could support a
family on one wage earner and a couple
of kids they're trying to destroy the
american dream
for themselves they've taken it off for
themselves remember they sit there and
they put that the party of davos with
that thing world you know build back
better oh you're not gonna own anything
but you're gonna be happy you don't need
to they own a lot because you're gonna
pay by the way
you're still gonna pay the rent right
are you gonna pay they're gonna own the
asset one of the reasons they own the
assets that's because there's an
explosion when you have this uh when you
have this printing of money there's an
explosion in real assets that real
estate stocks this is what's going up
they're the owners that you're seeing
the greatest concentrations shifting
concentration of wealth in mankind's
history right before our eyes that's why
it has to be stopped now you do have
power the debt ceiling they can't they
can't really get any of the spending
done until they increase the debt
ceiling and that's where the people
you're gonna have you think you had a
fire i called a firestorm
about this uh about the uh going back to
school on september 20th when they come
back from this recess and they have to
get down to brass tax the raising of the
debt ceiling is going to be the next
firestorm they're going to sit there and
go the deplorables and bannon and all
these crazies are going to ruin the
credit rating in the united states
they're going to implode the stock
market they're going to blow up the bond
market and do all this evil stuff right
all i'm saying is that
the full faith and credit you have three
ways to pay for things you sell bonds to
the japanese or chinese you raise taxes
and grow your way with increased taxes
or you print money
the only reason we can print money
remember the only reason we print money
is we're the prime reserve currency the
greatest export we have is the us dollar
every transaction in the world today now
the chinese are trying to get off it
cryptocurrency could get you off it but
every transaction in the world has to be
generally converted into a dollar that's
why it's the greatest asset the greatest
export we have as long as we have that
we can keep printing money but all that
printing of money when it says the full
faith and credit the united states
that's you that's your audience it's on
your shoulders that means you're gonna
pay it back your hard work your efforts
the world's depending upon you the
decency the decency of the american
people to make good on an iou and that
day that is now 30 trillion dollars you
project this thing out it's it gets so
far over the top and no
economy
they always say this time it's different
it's never different
once you cross once you cross uh debt to
gdp boom and that's what we're hurtling
down this now they're here talking about
six trillion dollars and here's the
question look around your city look
around your state look at your own
personal life don't take my word for it
we're at 30 trillion dollars face amount
roughly 30 trillion dollars a face
amount of debt by the way the contingent
liabilities depending on your discount
rate anywhere from 110 to 250 trillion
dollars contingent liabilities but just
on the 30 million a 30 trillion look
around at your state where'd the money
go
where did the money go where did the
money go do you see great airports you
see magnificent highways you see great
light rail where did the 30 trillion go
where the two trillion go in afghanistan
but it's brown university the net
present value of what we spend in
afghanistan is two trillion dollars this
is what i asked when i was in the nsc
show me the hospitals show me the roads
show me the schools for girls this is
gotta be shangri-la it's 30 it's the
size of texas is 35 40 million people 2
trained this has got to be shangri-la
where did the money go right a lot of it
was left on the runway there in uh was a
kabul for the taliban to take in the
form of jets and fighter jets that's a
little bit yeah millions of dollars each
i mean hundreds of millions on hundreds
kind of answering a question you
probably know the answers
the arms industry they make a bomb they
blow it up it's gone but they spent a
lot of money 20 million dollars making
the stupid thing or whatever they
decommissioned the jet the next year
look hundreds of millions of look these
are fighters and let's be honest we
created help create the taliban to fight
the russians back in the back in the uh
back in the 70s and 80s or charlie
wilson's war but listen
the afghan people have defeated
essentially alexander the great the
british empire at the top of their game
the soviet empire at the top of the game
and let's let's we've taken
the afghan national army
for
hundreds of billions not 80 billion
hundreds of billions of dollars of your
money
we took the world's greatest fighters
toughest fighters to beat everybody top
of the game
and turn them into the world's worst
army that quit that quit
because you've been lied to you've been
lied to for 20 years and we accepted
these lies but uh uh to clarify though
they did quit but it was uh biden my
understanding is he pulled air support
and logistics yeah they pulled logistics
out of the system they they pulled the
maintenance they they fled bagram air
force base in the middle of the night
and then the afghan security forces are
like where's our support we have this
training this doctrine and all of a
sudden it's crippled when the when the
taliban starts coming in and the
commandos did fight there's that video
where the commandos run out of ammo and
then surrender and the afghan i'm sorry
the taliban just come in and kill them
all
eventually after weeks of this that's
when you see everyone just disband it
fell apart this whole aspect of what
happened in may june july and what biden
was told what what intelligence was told
this will be
in if not an impeachment trial
hearings that lead up to this because
this is that grave what was he told what
was the decisions made what was the
logic and who signed off of taking
giving up bagram first taking the troops
out first and leaving american citizens
there and the thing how do you do it in
reverse order who made those decisions
what intel what were the briefings
what'd they look like right here what
milli said
he was ordered to to guard the embassy
so they didn't set up a path to bagram
an air force base where they could have
been running evacuations instead they
tried doing it out of kabul's
international but this is where general
austin and general miller got to step
there and go no we can't do this because
you're going to jeopardize you know we
know you're commander-in-chief but we
cannot do this and make the national
super national security advisor in the
run-up to this is he working 24 hours a
day jake sullivan no he's down in brazil
lecturing bolsonaro on machine voting
for the for the for the big contest
they're going to have in 2022 between
lula the the communist criminal and
bolsonaro a populist nationalist he's
down there lecturing him about his
election lecturing about election when
he should be in the situation room 24
hours a day we're sorting this thing out
all of that will come out now we're in
the middle of a crisis where they've
basically had the taliban tell them no
31st is a hard date you're out and
they're going to move the apparatus and
we don't know how many american citizens
look i spent months and some people
spent years in the north arabian sea and
persian gulf back in i think 79 80 for
the
for the persian for the iranian hostage
christ there were 52 people we have
thousands and we don't know tim how can
we be sitting here in on august 24th and
we don't know today within a couple of
thousand how many actual american
citizens are and i'd say they're
hostages right now or because you're at
the tender mercies of the taliban to
allow them to go to the airport to get
out of there what was it movie with uh
ben affleck where they were uh trapped
in iran it was based off the true story
dude i'm talking about it was like in
the 70s i think it was this is there's
something more about ross perot sending
his guys in to get the uh well in iran
what happened is that they took the
embassy in iran and tehran yeah right
and to sneak the people out well no we
had no the ross perot had a company and
he had employees there he he went and
did helicopter things he took his people
out we after a year or nine months of
humiliation
tried to send an attack force to get him
from the persian gulf in north arabian
sea it got to a rendezvous point and
kind of crashed and couldn't go couldn't
go into tehran we abandoned it
the day of ronald reagan you talk about
peace through strength and being and
somebody being afraid of the new sheriff
the day of ronald reagan's inauguration
the mullahs sent the sent the hostages
back all of them right now one they want
to humiliate carter but more importantly
they knew there was a guy in town that
was not going to put up with this
nonsense okay that's what we're seeing
look you can hate
you can spit on the floor when you hear
donald trump's name
just be brutally frank
okay that's the world was not like that
last year okay it just wasn't okay now
we have a feckless hapless old man
that's clearly not in charge making
disastrous decisions the other question
i got
why do you have a president i say that
addresses the american people in the
middle of the afternoon
okay
why does he be before the sundowner why
is he doing things at three o'clock in
the afternoon 3 45 4 o'clock on the west
coast it's lunchtime you're addressing
the nation can you can you can you
they'll give you tv time this is a big
enough crisis i think they'll give you
tv time or even if just cable picks it
up let's have a talk at eight o'clock at
night when people are back from work
when people are back from work i mean
these are these are national things look
there's no floor
and talk about no coincidences rachel
maddow cuts her new deal rachel mcshe's
cause she's the brains of the operation
she's you talk about the media she's
she's the the thinker and her team is
all of a sudden she wants to spend more
time with the family she's cutting a new
a weekly show from a nightly show and oh
she's gonna start doing west wings and
entertainment and you know ari emanuel
you know and she's going to do all kind
of things no
she just like jon stewart she does not
want to be left holding the bag here she
wants out okay she wants out and
i want to spend more time with the
family give me a break she's the hardest
worker and tougher and hey on the rise
of this she was all over it she's seen
it and they want out of here because
they understand
this is a debacle this is a debacle the
entire
every one of our allies is repulsed and
the chinese communist party a
transnational criminal organization with
their partners in pakistan that have
been run been continuous for years with
now the taliban in the in the in the
super state with al qaeda haqqani and uh
in isis
plus turkey plus russia is now going to
consolidate the eurasian land mass and
they're going to be looking at silicon
valley west which is taiwan forget
whether you think you have a moral
obligation to defend a democracy think
about the practical you're not going to
have a refrigerator you're not going to
have an f-100 you're not gonna have an
economy because that bill they're trying
to jam through is 20 billion dollars to
try to get the high-tech chip design
back to arizona it ain't going to happen
taiwan is silicon valley west it must be
defended for the practicality of the
american economy and they're sitting
there right now looking at island 100
miles off in this hapless crowd here
that are going to leave american
citizens behind
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel
youtube.comcast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you